good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday hope
everyone's having a great day hey jax
how you doing i'm doing well i think i'm
doing better than you yeah well we're
getting a little bit of a late start
today because the elevators in our
studio were down um one of them has been
down for a while the other one's been
like on its last leg yeah and today was
the day that they gave out and we i had
to take the stairs and i gave jackie a
heads up because you're pregnant i
called you i got here first i said the
elevators are down there's another
entrance on the other side of the block
like and that one has like a service
elevator so i told you to go and i
braved this channel she walked up the
stairs 30 minutes ago
my knees
and she is not okay she's still not okay
my knees are so weak like i feel dryness
in my throat do you need water and i
know everyone's like it's dramatic it's
only five sets of stairs let me just say
one thing first of all the ceiling
height in every in our unit is like so
high
so it's really like two flights per one
flight per floor so it's really i would
say i walked 10 flights of stairs and i
just can't breathe like i can't breathe
i'm so exhausted like i feel like
literally tyler's friend after he ran
the marathon like my nipples are
bleeding
oh wow okay well i hope that you come to
yourself at some point no i'm having
like a lot of mucus builds up in my
throat like i'm i seriously need to go
to the hospital oh my god well first you
need to deliver the past five stories
then you can do whatever you want 100 we
had the busiest day ever yesterday like
meetings meetings meetings podcast
podcasts podcasts photo shoot photo
shoot photo shoot and
it was really fruitful so we have so
many announcements to share so let's go
in order of events first of what we did
yesterday first we recorded a new
patreon episode that is up now and it is
my bump date part two it's all things
bump sessions
baby's name so you should really go over
it
um everyone submitted their questions
for me and i answered them claudia asked
everything that you know she could
possibly think of how i'm feeling what
i'm thinking what i'm doing what are my
plans and you can listen to that over at
patreon.com morning toast it was a
really fun sweet episode
then we have something so exciting to
announce
our holiday winter merch collection is
dropping on thursday so really soon you
guys we were taking all of our promo
pics yesterday which will be up like
once this episode
they'll be up later today so you can see
everything that's going to be for sale
we have this like on our ass photo shoot
we did no you're so cute you guys are
going to like be like oh my gosh who are
those cuties no like we're those cuties
at the plaza like is that eloise no it's
jackie and claudia yeah so
all the things that we are selling will
be up on our instagram you can check
them out and it launches on thursday we
want to make sure everybody gets their
holiday time way before the holiday and
you know we're all about the holidays
being in november oh yeah no but we just
want you guys to have enough time to
plan to buy now with this collection
it's unlike other collections because
once it sells out there will be no
restock
there's a limited i mean we ordered a
lot of stuff but it is limited so once
it's gone it's gone so if you know what
you want i would recommend signing on
early as always amazing the collection
will launch at 10 a.m eastern time at
shopmorningtoast.com
on thursday so definitely set your
alarms for that this stuff is so cute
it's so sick it's so cozy yeah it's
really holiday vibes it gets you in the
mood we have ornaments we have beanies
we have yeah
a lot of the stuff that obviously
everyone wants to know toasty lights of
course we brought back toasty lights i
would say better than last year so every
year we do a toasty light sweater and we
just keep on upgrading i love this
year's toasty this one has some texture
yeah this one is super cute you guys
will see everything new in the coming
days and it's very exciting also if you
haven't gotten your merchant from the
last drop everything will be shipped out
in the next week and a half so like in
past collections when something sells
out we're able to order more pre-order
keep going but everything for the
holiday collection is custom so it was
ordered a while ago and there will be no
reordering we literally designed this
collection like a year ago yeah it's
been sitting in our studio for like six
months and we finally got to like put it
on and take pictures yesterday and this
[ __ ] is so sickening like you've never
seen anything like this in your life no
like we have a set of pajamas that are
so comfortable i think i'm gonna order a
few more pairs just i need one for every
night no i know they're so comfortable
they honestly feel just as good dare i
say better than my skin's ones you know
they are so great delicious light and i
that those are the kind of pajamas i've
been living in and i need one for every
night of the week
so i'm going to order six more totally
shop morningtoast.com thursday 10 a.m
eastern time and i just can't wait for
the pigs to come out we look so cute
yeah no it's some really really cute
stuff and this way you have like you can
plan if you want to get a gift for
someone
if you need some stocking stuffers this
is the place to go so we're really
excited to share all of that with you
it's an exciting week here at tmt it is
big week big things show on thursday
when it rains it pours oh yeah you have
your first show how are you feeling i'm
feeling really like awful i can't lie
like really nervous like i'm having
imposter syndrome i'm having like
disassociation from my last tour like
i've been practicing like non-stop i i
feel horrible like i just i'm so nervous
i think that's like how
you're supposed to feel like i think so
too and until you get out there and it
slaps you're going to feel this way you
know totally like it's going to slash i
will not rest until thursday i will not
feel happiness until thursday thursday's
a big day yeah huge i'm excited to hear
some of your show me too you're going to
be sharing with me oh yes oh after this
yeah i need jackie's input you know i'm
i just like need to run everything by
everyone because i make like you know
embarrassing but she's back in ever run
everything by everyone yeah no and it's
so annoying she tried it out here on her
own for a while also you know i'm like
so um
like when it comes to my comedy i'm not
like a dave chappelle like i don't say
anything crazy i really like talk about
myself but if you know i've thrown in a
couple like crazy jokes and i just need
to run them by you like i can't get
cancelled again you know for sure but
you're talking to the wrong person
because i'm gonna say go yeah you know
you're
wild
i mean it's funny
i agree funny it's funny but like the
worst is you say something and it's
crazy funny yeah oh god yeah oh no
totally
that's like in um
hacks
when she like the the young writer yeah
what she got cancelled for and the old
writer was like well that's just gonna
be funny totally yeah um so yeah those
were our housekeeping announcements
yesterday was just like busy business
women being busy
um and we have an amazing show for you
guys i think we have like five and a
half stories is that correct we do like
there was just it was chaotic it was so
much like little mindless stories all
the stories are quite small so
there were six of them and
i guess we'll call it five and a half
the fast five and a half and we also
have dear toasters because it's tuesday
so we have like a busy
action-packed day we do and i think we
should jump right in i'm in agreement so
without further ado it is time for the
fast five stories fast five and a half
stories that you need to know before you
wake up and take a bite out of your
morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
all birds all birds make cozy shoes and
apparel from premium natural materials
they're not just comfortable they're
better for the planet all birds are the
gifts that feel as good as they give as
nope all birds are gifts that feel as
good to give as they do to wear all
right everyone's wearing all birds like
they're everything of the sword it's a
great gift for someone they're stylish
they're good for the environment and
they're super super comfortable their
classic wool runner
um the wool piper and the new fluff
collection make great gifts that keep
you comfortable wherever your feet take
you perfect thing to place under the
tree like a new pair of sneakers i think
that all birds are actually an amazing
gift and
nobody doesn't like their all birds
they're so comfortable they're so
stylish you can wear them just to parade
around town you can also wear them to
work out i would wear them to the live
method do some heavy lifting and my
oddboards would provide the support that
i needed and the best part is that they
are on a mission to reverse climate
change they are a b corp but making the
environment a stakeholder in their
business we can create a more
sustainable future together but only if
we tread lighter on the planet so give
comfort and feel joy this holiday season
find your find your own pair or one to
gift at allbirds.com today that's
a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s dot-com
check it out
just do it yeah
okay first story miles keller is in the
news um
one we need to talk about the video
which i finally watched and two he's
revealing that he has been vaccinated
against covid 19 for a while
my website is stalling is it daily mail
no it's page six maybe it's just my ipad
you know i've had this ipad for like you
know what since the breath
what yeah i i got it right before we got
cancelled and then i was like well now i
have a little bit too like that
um but that's a really long time ago i
mean it's still you would never know
it's like an old ipad but like no it's
just making me think because i have an
ipad that ben got for me like for a
hanukkah or something when i was living
in this apartment so like somewhat
recently and it looks 10 years older
than yours yeah i also feel like the
more you use your things the better they
stay up if you don't turn on your ipad
for a year it won't ever turn out no but
you know your camera on the ipad's like
really aging it's giving me away yeah
okay it's giving early 2000's iphone you
guys i'm going to try and read this
article as quickly as possible before
the page refreshes again miles tyler
announced late monday that he's been
vaccinated against kovid after taylor
swift fans worried about his appearance
in her i bet you think about me music
video he said hey guys i don't usually
reload this page again
glad it's tweaking hey guys i don't
usually feel the need to address rumors
on here but i am vaccinated and have
been for a while the only thing i'm anti
is hate okay i feel like he could have
left that last line out
i mean
i'm sure it's really annoying no you
weren't explaining the situation to me
so i had heard this like rumor that
miles teller wasn't vaccinated on jumois
it all started on jamal like someone
wrote in like blah blah that and he you
know closed down this one set of a
project he's working on and then he
actually has coveted and he's working on
an a-lister's movie set taylor he had
covert over the summer this is what the
jumuah thing said okay and it just
became this like larger-than-life rumor
just like everyone basically saying like
factually with no proof like miles
teller's not vaccinated and then the
daily mail wrote an article about it and
they actually reached out to miles this
was like yesterday reached out to miles
reps and miles reps were like you the
facts that you have are completely
incorrect and they still ran the story
so it's like what's the point in
reaching out to someone's
rep if they're telling you that's not
true like where's the accountability
right and also i'm sorry where's the
accountability on dumas like you can't
just start rumors like right it's it's
like actually not fair no it's really
crazy this is particularly a crazy um
instance of just people saying whatever
they want especially when it's like not
true and i'm telling you that it's not
true and you still don't [ __ ] care
yeah and no and honestly i also think
like this whole
concept of the rumor in general is
bizarre and i think i'm i don't know if
this is like a crazy thing to say but
like
like let's say miles teller wasn't
vaccinated like
so like you know i i just i feel that
way personally i personally think it's a
choice a lot of people feel the way you
do they're just not the ones speaking up
right so don't come for me i just think
like it's a weird thing that it's like a
new story not like people's medical like
decisions like is that private yeah i
mean it's supposed to be private it
should be private
this is not private for most people
everybody is being judged for their
decisions literally buzzfeed news
article tomorrow claudia ashrae is not
vaccinated claudia ashrae is very
vaccinated you know and i just think
like i think it's a bizarre thing like
that
people's medical choices are like
becoming news yeah and i know that's not
like a pc thing to say i just i think
it's weird no i totally agree i think
people should have the right to medical
freedom and to privacy i agree and also
like what we're just like making things
up out of thin air like what is the
proof right where's the proof right i
think the proof is that he's friends
with aaron rodgers and that just does
not hold up in a court of law no
no no no and he's like a working actor
and like if you want to be making
projects right now like you have to be
vaccinated like we were just talking
about who was it um ice cube stepped
back he didn't want to get vaccinated he
dropped out of a movie yeah so that's
like what you have to do if you work in
hollywood so i have to assume like most
people are like so
he's working on top gun like he's
vaccinated yeah like people just making
things up out of thin air it's like i
thought we were beyond that where's the
ethical naturally i take that back no
also this all came up because of the
taylor fans were worried about his
presence on the music video set which i
watched a music video yesterday and it
was
so good i mean if i can just make one
complaint it would be i would have liked
more kelly i would have oh of course
yeah she honestly got chafted like with
the veil behind her face like show us
her gorgeous beautiful stunning and
smart face like she's so cute she's so
pretty and you know she was having like
the best day of her life it was
such a great video and miles is such a
great actress i really felt like i was
watching a movie no i know
first of all like are you just throwing
up
i get like uh like like heartburn
sometimes yeah
no no no it's not painful it's just like
sometimes like maybe it's acid reflux
where it like comes up and it's like i
could throw up oh my god imagine if you
just threw up on the show i mean you've
choked yes i would have put it past you
let's do it i mean it could be good for
clothes yeah okay next time i'll be so
clickbaity we'll make like a crazy
thumbnail like host throws up mid show
you know okay next time i won't surprise
it just let it out yeah free space okay
cool cool um yes back to kelly she
didn't get nearly enough airtime the
video video was so stunning and for me
like every single one of taylor's looks
like i don't know what was my favorite i
think when the wedding dress turned red
was like so sickening also that big
shoulder red dress she wore when she was
eating the cake and that sickening
flight attendant look in the very
beginning yeah so good it was all
so sickening it was really a treat after
we just had a short film it was my cup
runneth odler we're being so spoiled i
do believe also there is a ronin music
video coming
ronan's mom is like very much you know
engaged in the swifty community and she
said i just saw the music video for the
first time like it's the most beautiful
thing i've ever seen in my life and
honestly like
i don't know if i will be able to handle
that and for those who don't know the
story behind ronin because not to like
gatekeep taylor swift but like everyone
likes her now but like
it's like annoying do you feel that
no like i feel like annoyed and like
protective and territorial that's
something i think you should work on no
i don't think this isn't the first time
yeah it will be the last time
and why can't you
open up your stand um no by the way i
can but like i just feel like we should
you don't have to no nobody's taking
away from you no that's not what i'm
worried about i just feel like everyone
should have to identify themselves like
what year did you become a taylor swift
fan because like i just think it's
interesting like you weren't there for
the hard times it's like easy to love
taylor when everyone loves taylor you
know but if someone wasn't exposed to
the music i'm just saying back in the
day like how how is that their fault i
don't see all these now exposed like she
was the biggest pop star in the world
it's not like she was like an indian no
but like you had no problem ever being a
taylor swift fan because you were always
like a country pop fan like she was made
for you but like some people have a
different journey that's totally fine i
just would like people like on their
social media to have it be in their bio
like because i just feel like there's so
many people like they're being
performative like like you don't know
anything you know
i'm sorry i just think it's true and
like they're doing it for like the clout
and for the clicks and for like
it's like so trendy now like to do
taylor content and i just think like
well so are you saying like people are
behave like people are
it bothers you that it can't be
bothering you that people are enjoying
her music for the first time not at all
are people acting as though they've been
they're like being a swifty freak like
you and but they haven't been there the
whole time is what you're saying that
and and i don't think that they're doing
it for the right reasons like i really
feel like they're just doing it for
clout like tick tocks like that's really
what i feel interesting yeah well i
could i could say five names right now
but i won't that's pretty losery i'm not
gonna lie of me no no of people like if
you're a new taylor swift fan like you
can't be swifty just yet like you
haven't been here no i know and it's
just like
i don't know it's really bothering me
but i was gonna say something else
we just this was supposed to be a side
note ronan thank you okay so ronan is um
a song on taylor's album that she wrote
based on this blog she read once about
this woman who lost her son ronan to
cancer he was four years old and she
just wrote this like beautiful blog
about like grief and ronan's like final
you know time on earth and it was so
moving and she just wrote a song about
it she reached out and she was like i
was very moved by this can i write a
song about it and she's only ever
performed it once at the stand up to
cancer benefit and it was like so
beautiful and i don't know how she
didn't cry and it's on the red album
it's on the new one too and um swifties
like know and love and follow ronan's
mom um actually was looking at her
instagram the other day
and she talks to taylor her and taylor
are still very much friendly and in
touch and she revealed on twitter that
there is a ronin music video so i
actually don't think like the the con
the sickening content from taylor is
over like i think we'll get actually a
few more music videos wow that's really
exciting and i didn't know that story
until like this week it's um it's such a
nice like story and like that's what's
so great about taylor like she does
these amazing things and like doesn't
even tell anyone about them you know
yeah
definitely and only true fans would know
that okay
i'm definitely gatekeeping taylor swift
and i'm i'm very proud of it i'm not
gonna okay as long as you know what
you're doing and you're comfortable with
that yeah 100 it's because it's
reminding me like when 1989 got so big
she was so popular yeah and then it was
ripe you know it was the rise before the
fall and like all those fairweather fans
who like fans who like loved blank space
and just like became taylor fans like
they were nowhere to be found when it
came to
you know taylor
going it's easy to love her when
everyone loves her but it's it gets hard
sometimes and i just i don't know i feel
like i feel resentful of people i do so
this is just giving me like pre-1989
vibes okay i hope that you're able to
work through that maybe you should talk
to somebody
like i can't i have too much to work
through right now like with my show like
you're so busy yeah but you have to make
time the merch is launching like i'm my
mental health as it pertains to taylor
swift is very much on the back burner
maybe next week maybe some free time
yeah also time off we forgot to tell
everyone we are off for thanksgiving the
week week that's why we just released
our first patreon episode of the month
if you're looking for episodes next week
they will be on patreon um but we are
taking a much needed vacation i'm so
excited me too i love being like
in the city
doing nothing during the holidays i
believe they call that a staycation yeah
but i hate the word staycation
okay like it's one of those words that
like it's chewy
i don't
i don't hate it i don't hate it but i
but i respect your right to hate it okay
good i like sends a chill down my spine
i actually hate it
okay our next story harry styles is
launching a beauty line and it is now
available to shop nail polish right four
nail polish colors two skin care
products the brand is called pleasing
and it is now available to order so he
is the latest in a string of celebs who
are launching a beauty line and i
actually think that this
is good this works i mean it's
it's unique you know
as unique as it can be like everyone's
doing you know some sort of beauty line
i don't know a lot of people who do skin
care i mean um who do nail polish except
for chris and take men so i think this
is good i think this is good and he
wears nail polish yeah and it's actually
been like a point of like uh controversy
people are like i'm always wearing nail
polish so you know what he's like owning
the narrative does he always wear like
ten fingers oh he does like you know one
here one there it depends on how he's
feeling who's the person on bravo who's
always wearing chef uh craig is always
getting one finger they should be sewing
down south polish they should collab
sewing down south polish i mean harry
styles is just one of those celebrities
like anything he launches will be
popular yeah but this but this is also
just a good idea based on his brand like
it's not so far-fetched it's not like
he's trying to sell like
makeup
that he doesn't wear
to girl like it's not like he's just
slapping his name on something like i
could believe that when he's wearing his
nail polish now like it is his brand
nail polish i agree um what are your
thoughts have you seen seen any of the
conversation happening around rem beauty
what's the convo well it was released
okay um and the convo is that it's just
giving very much claires which i did
agree with it is a lower price point but
i also was thinking like who are
ariana's fans like people who shop at
claire's like also like i'm completely
here for claire's i think it's one of
the happiest stores in the world
it's such a good time you can get so
much fun stuff there for so little money
yeah and it's great for
it's great for preteens and teens like
right i'm sorry not every beauty brand
needs to be 50 foundation yeah so yeah i
actually also like the the
her young fans like aren't wearing
foundation like they're wearing like fun
glitter i didn't i haven't even seen
this stuff i just saw that kim got the
pr package which was
noteworthy because of pete right but
also kim in the pr video gave it to
north perfect perfect so i think that
just a lot of people were unclear on
what it was going to be
and were disappointed in the sense they
thought it was going to be like at
sephora and i think actually it's a
great way to like stand apart from like
you're never going to be
uh fenty and you're never going to be a
rare beauty like do something different
something young kids and that's who goes
to ariana's show i think that if ari
like wanted to do something like rare
beauty that she could have achieved that
but it's being done her audience is so
much younger that's so much fun and
they're glitters yeah they're morphy too
that's what i was thinking and there's a
space for it i think it's a great idea
justice for claire's i'm sorry calling
something claire's is not insulting to
me no i only have positive associations
like you could just get anything there
would totally just uh your style you did
a pair of fake glasses that looked real
and like you know and this nerd who
takes off his glasses and everyone
realizes she's handsome and when we were
kids we did not have our ears pierced
and like claire's was the only store
that really catered to us they like the
little sticky ones we had many many
options we did you could get like
headbands you could get fun scrunchies
you could totally change up your look
you could reinvent yourself at a decent
price no very fair competitive prices
i'm all here for claire's i'm i'm
actually it makes me proud of ari that
that's the road that she went down i
think that's most fun for her fans yeah
and you know what i think it's high time
we stop comparing things to claire's as
an insult like it's not no it's not it's
fun for the whole family i like i only
have positive associations if i was in a
mall right now when i saw claire's like
i would probably walk in
yeah still yeah yeah that's so much fun
so cute you could get such great inspo
there yeah and you know i've seen
youtubers do like a full face of
claire's makeup and it's cute yeah
okay so officially it's my ipad that
keeps crashing not these websites
because now we're moving on to the daily
it's time for a software update oh i
think they were bugging me about
something yeah just charge it overnight
and let it do its thing it's fine i can
ad-lib
next story ready for it it's not up yet
no no it's i'm ready are you ready oh
yeah
down to abby the movie two trailer is
here and the crew is going to the french
riviera oh it's like dead ass not
working you know it keeps just like
crashing restarting crashing like oh man
i know um okay the trailer looks so
gorgeous like love seeing the gang back
together and what i found most shocking
about the entire announcement was that
maggie smith has returned and spoiler
alert
in the last film she sat down with
michelle dockery and was like i'm sick
i'm not well i won't be here much longer
it's your job like kind of passing on
the the crown um so i assume that meant
she's done with the franchise like she
wouldn't be in the next film i think
that so maggie smith i believe has
graves disease yeah so i think that in
the last film they left it like that so
that if she couldn't be in the second
film it wouldn't be a gaping hole but
the fact that she can be there is just
so stunning and it's amazing it's a
miracle premise for this movie is that
dowager countess has inherited um a
villa in the south of france dad would
your countess comes into money yes she
has like a former lover who i guess left
or something like the quarter
and the crew is headed to the french
riviera so do they spend a lot of time
at
downton like that's my favorite part of
the well there were downton shots for
sure but i think there's also a bit of
travel i also saw a clip it appears as
though tom gets married there was like a
wedding and i saw tom kissing someone oh
yeah and in some of the pictures he was
holding the hand of a lady so i wonder
if it's the woman from the last movie i
feel like no
but i would like that
because she came into my name
and
right it was like the it was
the queen's assistant's like love child
or whatever yes
i would love there was a point where
like i really thought like the perfect
ending to the show was going to be like
michelle dockery and tom getting married
like
you know back in the day like it wasn't
weird for like your sis dead sister's
husband to like marry you you know yeah
but they had a kid so that is if they
hadn't had a kid maybe yeah and also
i'm good they were just like getting so
close like becoming real family that
like i was like maybe like these two
could [ __ ] you know but i'm glad the way
it ended you know yeah no i'm really
excited for the movie it comes out in
march which is a little disappointing i
was hoping you know for a holiday
special it's a huge miss i'm not gonna
lie yeah you know i i have to believe
that they were striving for christmas
yeah maybe delays with cobid like yeah
and the other movie the first movie came
out over the holidays like and i think
it did really well for them but i'm sure
you know with coven and i guess i'm just
glad it's not holidays 20 23. totally
and like i'm just glad that like this is
the first time i'll be like on on time
you know
like i watch them they'll be arriving to
something with everyone else like i
watched the series and the movie like
years after they premiered and now i'm
like a part of something and you know
how much that means to me yeah i'm happy
for you thanks
are you ready but do you think that
there's someone out there who's
gatekeeping downton abbey and is upset
that you're like coming in
the final hour that's a really good
question let me tell you why i don't
think so but it's very possible if they
did i would respect that i really would
because i am the definition of like a
bandwagon downton fan the reason why i
don't think that it's because it wasn't
like there was like this big hoopla like
about downtown that like got me involved
like i just picked it up you know like
out of sheer curiosity and interest so
you so if someone just has picked up
taylor out of sheer curiosity and
interest no it's they're like i feel
like people are picking together up
right now because of the hype and it's
like so easy and fun to be like a part
of something everyone's already a part
of you know what i mean like it lacks
originality it lacks creativity yeah but
so how would that downton gatekeeper
know
that you because i picked up downtown
like years after the show ended years
after the movie came out like i just
like it piqued my interest okay and i'm
not claiming to be like the number one
downton stan like of all time like i'm
not like you probably know more about
like the family and like you know like
you like i just i'm not like an
encyclopedia like i still get confused
about like who's related to who you know
like i'm not pretending to be like the
biggest downturn ever where i feel like
a lot of people on social media are like
acting like taylor swift's biggest fan
like i know you hadn't heard red up
until two days ago got it and that
[ __ ] pisses me off and that i
continue to keep and i'm very proud of
okay i look forward to you telling me
who
i have like four people in mind great i
can't wait to hear offline yeah
are you ready for our next story only if
it's a story that's brought to you by
zotek skin care are your years of acne
gone yet still struggling with the dark
marks and acne scars that time left
behind well zotique skincare is artfully
crafted for all skin types and uses
scientifically powered ingredients to
deliver the complete results your body
deserves
zotik's new deep correcting serum
provides the benefits of lactic acid
with zero irritation to your face
combined with cutting-edge skin care
technology to deliver the purest vitamin
c effortlessly to the layers of the skin
that need it most this new deep
correcting serum promises skin
that is smooth as silk free from redness
and a visible reduction of acne scars
i've actually used this product for a
few weeks now and i can definitely
attest to the fact that a lot of my
redness has gone down and it really
really hydrates the skin i've heard that
lactic acid is really good for your skin
and i had never used it before and i'm
seeing and feeling visible results and
if you want to get 15 off zotik's
breakthrough deep correcting serum go to
zotiqueskincare.com that's
z-o-t-i-q-u-e-skincare.com and enter
code toast15 at checkout to get that 15
off again that's zotekskincare.com
z-o-t-i-q-u-e and toast 15 is the promo
code to get 15 off and your order is
shipped free to your door with
guaranteed results before the last drop
or you get 100 of your money back that's
zotik skincare.com code toast for 15 off
great thank you claudia it's a pleasure
i've migrated over to my phone because
these technical difficulties are not
going to work oh okay you know like
that's how i do the show when you're not
here because like i do have an ipad and
it's always dead and i only pull it out
when i have to go on like a 15 hour
flight got it well snl star kenan
thompson sells a humorous memoir for a
one million dollar payday saturday night
live veteran keenan thompson has sold a
memoir for one million dollars
publishing insiders exclusively tell
page six that's a lot of money yeah a
source said that the comedian had two
book concepts in the works and that he
sold the humorous memoir for a seven
figure payday perhaps that means he has
another book that he's working on but
seven figure could also be nine million
like that's true yeah it would be the
first tome for thompson but the book
arrives in a long line of printed matter
by snl stars and alumni including tina
fey tracy morgan david spade colin jost
gilda radner amy poehler j moore and
others oh you know i never thought about
it but i should read tracy morgan's book
i know all those books like i was just
getting you know some books
keenan is the longest serving cast
member in the nbc sketch comedy show's
history wow having started on snl since
2003. i knew he was the longest running
like that's there right now but i didn't
know in the history of the show no
that's insane that's amazing i mean this
book sounds so good well let's not
forget keenan was like a nickelodeon kid
keenan and cal he was on like a dan
schneider show like i'm sure he has a
lot of [ __ ] to say about like the whack
ass [ __ ] that went on at nickelodeon
back in the day yeah no i think that
this is gonna be such a great book like
i am as a reader very excited about this
me too and i feel like there's just a
lot of different layers to keenan like
obviously he's very funny but you know i
actually been in an uber with a driver
who said he drove keenan to snl once and
he was the nicest guy of all time like
he's just like a real humble guy like
from the neighborhood and i think that's
all really going to come through in the
book and i'm very much looking forward
to it yeah i was actually voting last
night the good reads you know the good
retap no yeah they came out with their
2021 like uh book awards and you can
vote in each category oh cute and
so i was you know making my voice heard
and in the memoirs and autobiography
category unfortunately you were snubbed
was i in it no you were snapped that's
disgusting i'm a new york times
bestseller no no it was like it was
clear it was glaring that like where
anyone else like who like are similar to
me in there yeah like every whatever
celebrity memoirs came out this year
which no but like not celebrity because
i'm like not a celebrity but like okay
like
like any reality stars are influencers
definitely influencers but i can't
remember what the [ __ ] yeah no it was it
was extremely hurtful but what i
realized was of all the ones that were
nominated i hadn't read any
this year i'm pulling out my goodreads
app how do i get to these voting and how
do i lodge a complaint i found that and
i actually oh jackie voted i see you're
the only person i follow on goodreads
did you tell you what i voted for yeah
we are the brennans oh my god that's
like really oh clara and the sun i'm
literally spreading information oh
goodreads choice awards okay [ __ ] these
people
nominees i also want to say so many of
the redheads books are nominated is it
memoir and autobiography would that be
me yes
i'm about to blow this [ __ ] up and i
also wanted i was gonna like post this
on my instagram story but it's like a
weird thing to post but like i shouldn't
vote in the goodreads awards like i want
to figure out what the best books wow
stanley tucci did you vote for him no i
didn't vote because i hadn't read any of
them okay i just want to say i don't
know anyone on here like it's not making
okay i feel fine like these are actual
famous people
i don't know like sicily tyson's book
was the biggest book of all year i would
never even like think to
even
orbit near that that planet i don't know
i see carlisle i mean hunter biden i
don't really hear a lot about that book
i think that's like rigged i'm just i'm
being honest like but not not to get
political but like
that sounds rigged um but a lot of these
books like every time i would like
refresh my new york times list like
checking to see if i made it they were
on here for weeks and weeks and weeks i
don't feel snubbed at all i really don't
i'm being honest it's so mature i
thought like you know like stassi was on
here i'm like those are my peeps like
get me in the book wasn't
yeah you know what i mean anyways it
just made me realize that i don't think
i read any celebrity memoirs this year
and that used to be my favorite genre of
book and like this is making me really
excited for keenan's book that's a
really roundabout way of what i was
trying to say there's actually a few
celebrity memoirs that are on my list
have you ever read colin jost no i heard
it's like it's critically acclaimed like
people love it okay maybe it's on my
list first yeah and then tell me yeah
there's a few celebrity memoirs but i
just can't remember which i agree i
haven't read one in a while but i was
feeling so proud because so many of our
redheads books are nominated a slow fire
burning how to fail at flirting clara
and the sun we are the brennans
d transition baby like
that's really cool oh by the way you
know there is this i follow them on tick
tock actually no i don't follow they
just like always show up so i don't need
to follow them but they're it's called
celebrity memoir book club and they do
so and they do they debrief the books on
tech talks you have to read the books
but they also do like a podcast
recapping it which is a really good idea
and they do like such random celebrities
that you never even knew had like they
just did um caitlyn jenner's i don't
even know she wrote a book when did you
write it i don't know that's so
interesting and yes i'm familiar with
celebrity book club we've had so good
i've done some redheads ads you have
yeah yeah oh look at you did an rss drop
oh yeah look at us
oh look at him hey
look at me
um so yes i will be reading this book
me too looking forward to it vote in the
goodreads awards they're not paying me i
just want them no actually don't don't
oh so i'm back to being bitter i'm back
to being bitter no i'm not going to
promote their like thing if you're going
to go do something they go to shop
morningtoast.com or just like join the
redheads or go to patreon um
or get but my book girl no job.com book
like but actually i was in the category
for like best fiction book of the year
and so many of them i never heard of
fiction is like just novels fake yeah so
many of them i had never heard of so i
screenshotted all them i'm like well if
these are nominated like maybe these are
best books how did i not hear them i
have to say like as a company i think
that like goodreads is like a really
good company i can't explain it it's an
amazing platform it's amazing platform
like it's just like a there are so few
corners of the internet that aren't like
ransacked with like hate and like racism
like it is just like this lovely
platform for readers to engage like you
can like things you can five star like
it's just it's seamlessly integrated
into kindle like i think it's really
i give them five stars all around as a
platform i really do i agree
it's just like no one's ever said
anything anti-semitic to me on goodreads
well you know i don't i don't want to
poke the bear yeah yeah exactly
okay our next story are you ready for it
i'm so hungry like oh you know what we
sat like because of the stairs like we
were like 20 minutes delayed and i feel
like this is the time like i would maybe
be having a snack you'd be reaching for
a snack i'm so crazy if you wanted to
get a snack and eat it while i read the
next story we could mute your mic you
know what i think is a better idea like
i'm ordering lunch i know people hate
when i do it on the podcast but we do
have a meeting like we need lunch so you
read i'm listening okay get my usual you
know what i like of course you actually
have already read this article because
you sent it to me i did tom sandoval is
ready to be taken he actually only read
the headline because that's all you need
to hear okay tom sandoval is ready to be
taken seriously as a musician after his
hollywood show unlike many of his fellow
bravo liberties who have dabbled in
music resident vanderpump rules showman
tom sandoval can actually sing p.t
barnum i'm sorry is rolling over in his
graveyard the 38 year old put his pipes
to you sunday night while performing
with his new nine-piece cover band tom
sandoval and the most extras can i say
that's a big band yeah that's like
unnecessarily big yeah and maybe that's
what they're trying to do weddings and
that would actually be a great idea but
i don't think that's the idea i think
he's ready to be stephen tyler right
him and his band are called tom sandoval
and the most extras because i don't know
if you know this about thomas sandoval
but his thing is doing the most and
being extra no that's a really i'm so
glad you brought that up because i
wasn't sure they performed at
hollywood's hotel cafe
there tom spoke exclusively which with
page six about his passion for singing
and his hope for a fair shot in the
industry despite his reality tv
notoriety he said when i first started
out crying well this this i found
interesting he said when i first started
out on vanderpump rules i thought i
might have ruined my chances of getting
into music or even acting i thought
people aren't going to take you
seriously you're just a reality person
but what i have found is that the show
has honestly been an amazing platform to
do anything really music is something
i've always loved and have always come
back to like a mistress okay
i was i was actually down for that whole
quote until the end
um standalone salmon on your salad
what kind of salad
this one that you like oh no no no no oh
no any substitutions and you don't like
the red peppers i don't like red peppers
no chicken dressing on the side you got
it for your girlie
anyways so this is the start of uh of a
new music career for tom sandoval he
actually has been on the show for years
like he was always doing music oh
touch in public yeah so hey
let's touch about this he's back to
pursuing that dream it's not like the
most far-fetched thing but this article
was extremely glowing and kind and we
really we need to hit up his pr person
yeah
um and we'll see where it goes from here
i mean everybody tagged me in the video
he posted so he what what song it was
like an old school he did like he's a
cover yeah but what song was that like
whatever so he did like this little
promotional video with his enormous band
and then it was promoting the fact that
they were having their first show and i
guess that's where page six got their
hands on him um and it's just they also
did like an accompanying photo shoot
which like is really quite sickening
that by the way that's very nice i feel
like probably um
tom provided the photos if i had to
guess oh yeah and then some of the
vanderpump gang are there
so i mean i'm happy for him like follow
your dreams but i'm not looking forward
to this storyline on the next season
nowhere and this is really just
i think for me like setting in i think
so many
not so many like i think tom sees and we
all see like what certain people did on
the show
and what they turned into like when you
think of stuff like stuff he's not even
on the show anymore and i would still
consider her the most famous person on
the show her podcast is enormously
successful and yes she's like very low
key right now because of like her baby
and obviously the big scandal but like
she will eventually go go back on tour i
think and she's writing another book and
writing another book like she has an
enormous platform with or without the
show which is an amazing thing and
that's something she like very
intentionally i think did during her
time on the show like but also it's like
you can't
you can try hard as you may yeah but
what
the people who stick
they just they they have that factory i
agree with that too yeah like a star's a
star
yeah and i do believe unfortunately tom
sandoval is not a star
remains to be seen i'm really trying to
be nice because like i'm just not in the
mood to like have a pit about being mean
okay i don't think i'm being mean i'm
just thinking like
okay lunch has been ordered sorry like
i'm so hungry okay do what you got to do
it's just it's giving cringe it's not
giving authentic like i don't i just
it's just giving it's giving cringe okay
i think that's fair sorry yeah also
speaking of celebrity memoirs and
stassi's next book um the title of it
came out we never talked about it but
it's called off with my head i believe
yeah and
it
is a great title yeah i actually um
i thought it was a great title too i
guess someone like [ __ ] up and put it
on google books well you have to like
eventually put it i don't know whether
it was of was that like it was like
something that like yeah but it's it's
on google now off with my head an intern
got fired over there no but it's still
on so i guess like i mean that happened
to me too but nobody cares about me so
nobody found it like got it it's off
with my head the definitive basic [ __ ]
handbook to surviving rock bottom
obviously she's been through quite a
scandal so i just think that'll be very
interesting i like the title a lot
because it's like cancel culture and she
also loves marie antoinette yeah um
i think that'll be good
lots of good books coming out
lots of good books should i write a
sequel
no honestly i feel like i've said what i
need to say yeah i need to live a little
bit more yeah and you just need to like
wait until you have something to say
right you don't can't force these things
no definitely not like i need another
scandal maybe i should just
keep going on about the vaccine maybe
you should keep those jokes in that
you're about to show me totally are you
ready for a fifth and a half story so
it's not the final no it's it's actually
like beyond the final it's the final
story
[Music]
it's five and a half because we love
hillary duff
yes it is
our five and a half story hillary
duffery creates her with love dance
after 2007 performance goes viral on
tick tock after a year's old performance
of hers went viral the 34 year old
actress joined in on the fun by
recreating her dance moves from her 2007
appearance on the tonight show with jay
leno she shared a video of herself
dancing along to her song with love side
by side with the original she joked in
her instagram caption that she only gave
into the trend so that she'd stop
receiving messages about the viral video
i have to be honest like i i actually
can very much believe that like
sometimes people send me the same thing
over and over and over again that i
almost want to post it to my story to
let you guys know that i've seen it but
you know what jackie like that's what it
means to be a star right and then i
don't because i'm like well
why am i complaining is that everybody's
thinking of you okay literally that's
exactly right so she said so i can
restock so i can stop receiving texts
about this peace sign also i tic talked
and it was a 12 kind of day
okay so
while i loved that this video went viral
i thought the guy who re so basically
like there are a couple like guys on
tick tock who were like make like doing
her dance side by side because it's like
such a weird dance it's like she's
giving it like five percent was that
what she meant by 12
even though she's giving like the dance
no energy and it's like so funny and
weird it's also like such early 2000s
dance moves it's really like this time
capsule adding you also i think at least
i forget a lot of the time like she had
this like solo career you know yeah so
when the video went viral i was living
for it and honestly like i didn't need
hillary to have to acknowledge it and
i'm gonna be really honest like i
thought the way that she did it was
really [ __ ] rude like she like
she posted it like so everyone can stop
tagging me and then on tick tock she
like ended the video and she was like
you're welcome and wrote you're welcome
in the comments too like no offense
[ __ ] like we don't need you like we
were having fun on the trend without you
like you're welcome actually to you for
making your like name relevant once
again reminding everyone about your
iconic solo career like i thought like i
actually really did not like the sense
of entitlement i was getting maybe i'm
looking too much into it who's giving
maui from moana you're welcome exactly
like it was giving entitlement i'm sorry
that is so funny like you're welcome
like we weren't waiting i wasn't i was
enjoying like the funny tick tock
creators who found the video who started
the trend like i was enjoying their
originality like i really didn't need
you to come on and like dump on it
i don't know if like anyone else felt
that way i was just maybe i'd like stop
when i was really like early this
morning
you're welcome i'm like
it really was like go [ __ ] yourself like
you're welcome
you're welcome we're talking about you
that's literally like your job
okay okay you're welcome
[Music]
okay
sorry
okay i'm glad you got that off your
chest and that was why we had to add
that as a story because claudia said she
had some i had some strong feelings she
wanted to share yeah and boy am i glad
that you did
um well we're not done yet i've got more
thoughts to share because it's tuesday
which means it's your toasters our
advice segment which you can submit to
if you wanted steer toasters
gmail.com write us in you can change
people's names we will not blow up your
spot ever and
and if you've also written us in
recently with an update we would no
sorry if you've also written us in
recently and we've read your quandary on
air please update us we want to know how
things went like did you tell the guy
did you not did you break up tell us um
and dear toasters is brought to you by
hydro jug
seriously one of our new favorite items
these durable and reusable jugs hold
more than half a gallon of water so you
will stay hydrated all day long
um
every celebrity has a hydro drug like
and you should too it's just a really
fun way to like stay on track drinking
water it's also a great stocking stuffer
i mean i don't know it's really big like
i don't know if you could fitness it's
gonna be like this only thing in there
yeah maybe it has to go under a tree but
it is a really good gift for someone it
is a great gift and if you are trying to
drink more water it is such an easy way
to get more water into your system and
it makes it fun it like gamifies it it
tells you like all the different
water levels that you're at and you just
feel really like in touch with your body
and i know that it's like so corny but
drinking water will solve all your
problems it really will um so here are
the specs it holds half a gallon of
water it has a leak-proof seal a wide
mouth opening
so you can like add fruit or ice it's
just like the perfect size um it's
bpa-free dishwasher safe and shatter
proof so it really they've just thought
of everything and it's a really really
great gift reusable obviously so much
better for the environment um and of
course we have a discount code if you
want to get your hydro jug go to the
hydro jug.com use the discount code
toast to get 10 off your order hydro
jugs are game changers for anyone on the
go again use code toast at the hydro
jug.com to get 10 off and start
hydrating today all right dear toasters
first up
hi jackie and claudia i first want to
say mazel tov to jackie on your
pregnancy and to claudia on your
upcoming tour thank you thank you
claudia my roommates and i can't wait to
see you perform in los angeles tickets
available at girlsnojob.com
when i listened to jackie and ben's
episode about transitional lenses i know
i knew i had to write in okay i've been
seeing my boyfriend for about a year and
he's the most thoughtful human being on
the planet the problem is his wardrobe
is horrendous he wears transition
lessons
he wears transition lenses
but that is the least of his wardrobe
problems he's such an attractive guy but
he wears truly horrible outfits and he
likes it
he'll put together like a crazy printed
top with shorts that don't fit and a
crazy printed mid-calf sock i've
mentioned him a few times that would be
nice if he wear clothes that fit more or
more simple outfits that match he always
responds with what he doesn't like
he always responds with
that he doesn't like dressing to be with
an in crowd and hate spending money on
clothes i'm working on getting him some
sample some staple pieces that i like
but i can't afford a whole new wardrobe
for him what do you suggest i do in this
situation sincerely a toaster in need of
advice okay i just want to say like
i think you should leave your boyfriend
alone i agree i would say let the man
live and like you say he's so attractive
so all of a sudden he starts dressing
like james bond and everyone starts
turning there now you got like new
problems no you have you have like
honestly a jewel like you have a man who
like is very very handsome but like
isn't aware of it because like he's
obviously dressing like a freak um and
that's great like let you get to see him
like without clothes on like you know
like i don't think you need to prove
anything i like
even though like me and ben have this
like point of contention like whenever
we go to a wedding ben's you know i told
you he goes to bloomingdale's like a
second before it drives me nuts and he
always wants to buy something crazy like
we're going to a black tie wedding it's
like all right check out like a rainbow
bow tie and i'm like no tom sandoval
stop like
it bothers me so much about tendencies
because ben always wants to wear
something crazy and i'm always like just
go with the black shirt in the black
pants like it's very slimming it makes
you look handsome like i'm always like
airing on the side of cymbal and he
thinks that's so boring and i've started
to call him bozo because he literally
like wants to wear these crazy things
and i'm like you look like a clown and
like i just don't know how to get
through to him like
you just have to dress normal like yeah
i guess it's like it's not about
him
like not like it's
there's a difference between like oh he
just has bad style but he likes what he
wears versus like he's dressing like a
clown and embarrassing me yeah 100 and
so and also when she does say like all
of these like patterns and like crazy
things so it's not like he just has like
bad style and he's like like a stain on
his shirt like it's like ugly clothes
yeah no and it's like but they're also
attracting attention so it's like quite
flamboyant but bad but isn't it like
but he likes it and it's it's not like
he's not thinking about it
he's putting things on why can't ben
dress like bozo well because we're
public figures and i just don't i can't
take the word so if you
oh okay yeah like i have a reputation
jump old and i can't like let ben leave
the house like looking like bozo okay i
think that's fair okay i didn't know
that that was playing and also because
like when i tell him what to wear like
he does look better like okay for
simon's welcome party like ben of course
wanted to bring his bozo energy and i
told him exactly what to buy at
bloomingdale's and he did and he looked
so handsome and the whole night he was
like oh man i look great
i'm at the fire alarm
should we go
i think we'll wait to see what everyone
else does let's see
are people filing out do you see smoke
do you no
am i seeing a reflection hold on oh my
god you're the scariest person alive i'm
so sorry
i'm seeing a reflection
of of smoke over there okay like
seriously i just had a heart attack
claudia's camera looked a little cloudy
like smokey
are you serious
doesn't it i'm just gonna check the
hallway hold on okay just go sniff
give a big sniff
wow this episode is beyond chaotic
from the stairwell
to the
it ipad really weird outside but not
like fire she says it smells weird but
not like fire
like chemicals wait it's off
okay well shut the door if there's
something funky outside
we can always exit through these windows
by the way and they have a staircase all
the way down the scaffolding okay
i'm just trying to protect my pregnant
sister yeah if it goes off again we'll
wrap the show and get the [ __ ] out of
here okay but it's definitely like i
maybe i'm just being crazy but it looks
like on the camera like we're foggy no
it doesn't stop no okay
okay let's move on before um you know
before we die before we need to evacuate
okay hello claudia jackie and brew and
do congrats jackie on the baby and
claudia on the tour i can't wait to see
you in dallas
tickets available at gardnerjob.com all
right i'll get into it i'm a long-time
toaster i need some advice i recently
this year had a friend breakup with my
childhood best friend of 15 plus years
she said some pretty terrible things to
me and i haven't spoken to her in months
because i removed myself from a very
escalated situation that occurred before
this time i was dating a guy for about
five or six months so i brought around
my family and around her for a few
events and long story short they are now
dating she posted an instagram story
this week with flowers he sent her he
never even gave me
a
he never even gave me a closer on the
situation of us ending and she also
never acknowledged her wrongdoing and
now seems to be with him to spite me
she's been going around saying terrible
things about me and it is heartbreaking
so my question is what do i do what
would you do if you were in my shoes my
heart hurts and all around i feel sad
humiliated but also in retrospect i'm
glad about my decision to distance
myself from both of them i appreciate
any and all advice on how to navigate
this thanks a sad toaster who's just
trying to be positive in this very
uncomfortable situation
tabi larassa
you just need wait tabularest in the
sense like you want to move forward with
them or just forget them like forget
them like i think you need to be like
you know sometimes you have your friends
then you have like other people that you
know and maybe put more energy into like
other avenues in your life and and start
building a new this is going to be the
lamest thing i'll probably ever say on
this podcast and i'll deny it till i die
but when people show you who you who
they are believe them it's true like
you're just now noticing like your
friend is not only a [ __ ] animal
saying disgusting things to you about
you to other people and now dating a guy
that you were dating very recently
she showed you who she is who the [ __ ]
would want to be around someone like
that it's not worth being heartbroken
over i pity this girl i feel sad for her
her life is miserable oh and this guy's
just like whatever who cares i just feel
like i'm now i'm just like really
concerned about the fire alarm but um no
i feel like we're really okay okay
you're not feeling like a little funny
what like sleepy no are you i don't know
i mean i'm just feeling weak from the
from the stairs still
oh wait go listen
there's an announcement
what did he say
i have news
he said we just experienced a false
alarm please disregard we're fine oh i'm
feeling so much better yeah you know but
it does smell really funky out in the
hall like i'm what i'm making our lunch
is here
okay now let me get back to the task at
hand i was i couldn't like hopefully
focus on everything but what i will say
is like
you know potentially this was very
nefarious behavior and like your friend
is just like a man stealing like [ __ ]
yep
but say for like what if they're meant
to be and it's true love and like that's
just how they met and that's really
[ __ ] awkward but
you need to look elsewhere for like i
think it's just i think you need to like
seriously just move on and forget about
both these people like imagine like just
never speak of them again yeah like
maybe i don't know like a nude city new
job it's time you have to move city
identity it's time for a new man and a
new friend like there's plenty of people
out there who are looking for friends
are looking for relationships so if this
man treated you the way that he did like
i why are we feeling rdh over the law
the la the
the loss of him and you know loss of the
right again
here full circle we're back to feeling
pity for her this man who's like not
capable of emotional intelligence is now
dating this awful human being they sound
like a match made in heaven yeah and you
know don't be surprised if they get
married yeah i do feel like they're
going to get married i don't know why i
just had this premonition because
they're both evil so yeah you need to
just
start a new new friends like
i don't know
you okay and just like you're so [ __ ]
fire alarm took everything out of me i
can't explain it okay well we have one
more okay i'm going to give him it's
long it's really long pay attention
please
hello claudia and jackie how you doing
good thank you i'm okay thank you for
all that better really thank you for all
that you ladies few laughs additions to
my vocabulary and stories i literally
use every day congrats on the tour in
the bib okay to the point of this email
part of the reason i started following
you guys is because i got engaged to my
now fiance during the pandemic last year
right around the time when i was
introduced to claudia and say yes to the
dress and then i found the morning toast
and i've been a loyal toaster ever since
amazing thank you say yes to the
backstory
you love to hear
we are not what just smells like a
barbecue he literally said it was false
alarm
what more do you want
unless some of the former toasters try
to drop us
okay
okay
we are now in the thick of wedding
planning finally trying to find a venue
and guest list catering et cetera it's
absolute insanity um when we first got
engaged we wanted to do a big to-do
to do but my fiance and i are both still
in school we have big plans for the next
two to five years that will require us
to move and we have been saving like
crazy our entire relationship for that
not a wedding when we talk about
finances for the wedding it's really
stressful and neither of us really care
about a big wedding we just feel really
pressured to by our families to have a
big one so recently my fiance and i made
our these people must be their list and
it was about 50 people then we made an
extended list of everyone we would want
to be there which was about 100 because
most of the smaller intimate places
we've seen have a 100 person cap while
he was adding people to the list my
fiance said a girl's name that that has
come up before as like a childhood
family friend
because their parents are besties
but i wasn't even gonna invite her
parents so like that's weird
when i asked about his aunt one i
particularly like and reminds me of my
late grandmother he said no because then
we would have to invite the entire side
of that family what this girl i've never
met i've been with my fiance for five
years is getting an invite and a plus
one on a very short list of guests that
we have already stressed about paying
for but not her family who i was under
the impression was the only reason you
actually knew her
and your aunt who i actually like isn't
there i feel absolutely crazy for
feeling a little peeved by this after
three years of living here and not
meeting her is it weird to want to meet
her before she gets invited to my
wedding why haven't we met if she's this
important he swears it's always been a
platonic relationship and she was there
for him through a rough time in his
teenage years but i'm so confused as far
as i know they hardly talk but once a
year
a maybe important note is we are in
school and super busy and apparently she
is too not that i know since i've never
met her and he says that's why we
haven't met please help me i need your
advice and wisdom love you lay whatever
words you have on me i need your help
sincerely an overwhelmed bride this is
so suspicious it's definitely weird like
why does this one random girl who you've
never even met in the last five years
get invited over his aunt like what like
what
also like why is he i think it speaks to
the character of your fiance like he has
100 people to invite and his aunt
doesn't make the list yeah no and you
know what this is some
it's shady you need to trust your gut
your gut is not leading you astray like
her name stuck out out of 150 for a
reason there could be 100 people in a
room but this is that girl for your
husband yeah no there's something weird
like 100
and i feel like a woman's intuition is
like i feel what you're saying like it's
giving me like one that got away vibes
and not that like he's in love with her
or anything but like she's just like
that girl for him that's like
no it's not giving me one that got away
it's like giving me like
there's this girl on tick tock i guess
one that got away implies like that
they're the relationship for you like
that you should have been with him i
don't think he's like wanting to go back
to her but like i just feel like you
know this is someone who he has feels
like special towards and you must make
sure they never see each other again
okay so there's this girl on tick tock
who does like this um like act she's
like the chill girl at parties and so
she does this thing where like
she's this really annoying girl she's
like not like other girls she like
drinks beers like everyone else and
this guy jason comes with his new
girlfriend and she like says the most
annoying things to jason like oh my god
like do you remember like when we're in
germantown like the beer we drink like
oh my god like you weren't there like
because you can't drink beer but like
she's so [ __ ] annoying it's just a
character but like you watch it you get
irate because like if a girl ever acts
like this this is what i'm seeing for
this guest yeah i just
you need to find a way to
make sure she's not invited and then
just keep your eye in your ears on on
the situation you know yeah but this is
a sign and trust your gut because you
didn't get that
internal red flag for nothing yeah no i
agree like shit's [ __ ] even if it means
you have to have a 50 person wedding
just so that she can't get invited as
151 and i think the message here is a
lope
yeah
yeah
also have you done like sufficient cyber
stalking i'm assuming right don't drive
yourself crazy because she wants to meet
her before the wedding like you can meet
her online like
you can find out everything that you
need to know
about her i just think it's weird like
if if this person is like that important
to your fiance you've been together for
five years and you've never met her like
they're obviously not important or
they're obviously hanging out without
you no they're so important and like
that's just not it's like you don't hang
out with your ex around your
with your fiance but she's not an ex
she's just like an old flame that never
sparked here's my advice
look into it yeah look into it keep tabs
on it and keep your wedding to 25 people
yeah
so she can't make it through the door
10.
okay that was your toasters again if you
ever want to write in or update us with
your problem us it's steertoasters
gmail.com and that was our show thank
you so much for listening to the morning
shows we've got to go because this place
might be burning down yeah thank you so
much for listening to the morning toast
monday morning show we deal with that
story you need each other monday friday
youtube supporters and youtube please
for subscribers and movies and thumbs up
we're also available and then we're
practicing we found something special
all right it goes back to all the places
where i guess more doesn't matter
um and if you missed the end of the
episode like leave a flame emoji because
because it's going down
i'm yelling timber have a great day
everyone we'll see you tomorrow for hump
day bye